- Hello, and welcome to
Ed Talks with Khan Academy
where we talk to influential
people in the education space.
Today, we are happy to welcome Ben Gomes,
who's the Senior Vice President
and the Learning & Education
Organization at Google.
Before we get into talking to him,
I wanna remind you that we are a nonprofit
here at Khan Academy.
And a lot of our work is possible
because of donations from folks like you.
So we encourage you if you
are in a place to do so
to find our sites and
give what you can to
keep supporting our work.
In addition,
as the pandemic
has happened
we have needed some additional support
to be able to continue
to provide the education experiences
to students who need them.
And we wanna specifically
recognize corporations
who have provided that support
including Bank of America,
AT&T, Google.org, Novartis,
Fastly, and General Motors.
Thank you.
In addition to this live video feed
you can also get an audio version
of our Ed Talks and Homeroom
with Sal in podcast form
wherever you find your podcasts,
look for Homeroom with Sal
and you will find us there.
So with that, I want to
welcome our guests today.
Ben Gomes, as I said,
the Senior Vice President
of Learning & Education at Google.
Ben, welcome.
- Thank you for having me here, Kristen.
And I also just wanna take the opportunity
as I saw the intro of
thanking Khan Academy
for the amazing work you've
been doing for so long
and especially during the
last year is just wonderful.
- Well, thank you.
And we are happy to do it.
Let's start off.
Tell us a little bit about your journey.
How have you come to lead the learning
and education group at Google?
What's been your path to get here?
- You know, if I think
about a lot of my career
a lot of it has been about
learning and curiosity.
I spent 20 years in search at Google.
And when I thought about
search, a lot of it for me
was about being able to answer
that curiosity of the moment.
Being able to get that
answer really quickly
that it stimulates more curiosity
hopefully in the long run.
And after working on search for 20 years,
I wanted to focus on learning more...
Learning and education more sort
of broadly across Google's products.
And if you think about Google as a whole,
Google's mission is to organize
the world's information
and make it universally
accessible and useful.
But a lot of information
is used for learning.
And it's used for changing
what people can do in the long run.
And a subset of that is
education where it's structured
and you get a credential at the end of it.
So, there's a lot of
aspects of Google's products
that can be used for that purpose
whether it's search or
YouTube or Classroom
or G Suite and workspace and so on.
That can be used for
learning and education.
I was really interested in that.
And I think it's a core
part of Google's mission.
So I think
it's a...
For me it was a really interesting...
It was following a path that
I've always been interested in
in some form or the other.
And
taking it to a deeper level.
- Got it.
Great.
Tell us a little bit about
your education journey.
Were there any particular teachers
who were particularly influential to you
and your success?
- Definitely.
Well, first of all, my mum.
(chuckles) She was a school teacher
and she taught geography
which is a subject
I don't think that taught
in the United States.
But, she was really influential
in like stimulating curiosity
because she'd take us out into
an area and then say,
you know how do you think
this landscape came to be?
And it got you thinking about like
how could this have happened?
And you may not know the exact answer
but just the process of
thinking was really great.
And the other teachers in my school,
there was a priest who
really influence my thinking
about the importance of
service and serving others.
And there was a chemistry teacher
who influenced not just me
but a whole generation
of students in my school
to go into the sciences.
He was a disciplinarian in a
mold that's not common today
but his passion for
chemistry was so evident.
And he in got to just so much
to do projects and to play
that a lot of us came to love chemistry
and through chemistry to
love science because of that.
- That's great.
So thinking about the field of education
and the intersection with technology.
Technology is changing
obviously very quickly but
we've seen some huge advances.
How do you think we can
bring those together?
What opportunities are
there because of technology
and the improvements in
technology we've seen?
- Well, I think we're here...
We need to figure out how to help teachers
in all kinds of different ways because
the key things that we
have tried to do in Google
is to try and understand
where we can help teachers
and learners actually
focus on the learning and
teaching task at hand.
And so that's a core part of
how we wanna think about the use
of technology in this space
as a tool
to help people whether it's the teachers
or the students to get what
they're trying to do done.
And so, tools like Classroom
are really structured around trying
to make the teacher's workflow process
and the students' work flow process easier
in giving out assignments and quizzes
and all these sorts of things.
And I think there are other ways
in which also you can
begin to use technology
in more complex ways in newer domains.
But the first aspect of
it is trying to figure out
what do teachers need?
What is the need of the day
that we can actually
provide using technology?
So I think it starts with a
teacher and what they need.
And then it proceeds from there
to the tools that need to be
built to satisfy their needs.
And I think that's the general framework-
- (chuckles) that's such a good point.
We often see kind of technology coming in
to tell teachers what they
need as opposed to asking them
how are you going about
finding out what teachers need?
- So it is a great, great question.
In an ideal world,
having taken on this role
I'd have loved to go into into classrooms
and actually ask teachers in person.
But I took on this job
in the middle of COVID
that's not been a possibility.
But we do get a lot of user
feedback from teachers.
We have a lot of forums
with teachers and so on.
And so we get a lot of feedback
when you use that really strongly
to prioritize what we're working on.
Because that feedback from teachers.
We can't satisfy all the
needs that they have.
But we prioritize based on
what they're telling us
is most important to them.
What causes them the most problems
and what would help them the
most in solving those problems.
- That makes sense.
So what are some of the things
that you see your group there
at Google working on in the future?
- So there's some very
interesting products that are...
First of all there's
further generations...
Further iterations of classroom.
We just announced 15 new features
in a couple of months ago
that we are still in the
process of rolling out.
Some have rolled out already.
Some will be rolled out.
But there are many other...
There are other areas too.
We have an app called Read Along
which is being used to help
children learn to read.
What it does is, it
does speech recognition
and voice synthesis
so that a child can reading
some text can get some feedback
on whether you're doing
it correctly or not.
And we're working together
with a nonprofit called Pratham
to actually see whether we do...
To try and change outcomes
and literacy levels for children.
And we've been able to see
like even a short time period
an improvement in literacy
with this nonprofit working with this tool
to help improve outcomes.
So I think there's a lot of different ways
in which in the future we
can begin to use technology
to help
in deeper ways in the classroom,
in helping the student get feedback
and in helping the teacher
give out assignments
and so on in a way that is effective
is more effective
than would be possible otherwise.
- Yeah.
So, one of the things that we can think
about technology doing
is maybe helping expand the classroom.
Expand out into the world.
Do you think there are
opportunities there?
- Yeah.
The role of technology today
is it has changed...
What technology is capable of
doing today has changed a lot.
When computers first started,
they were very good at doing things
that humans were terrible at doing.
Large computations,
complicated mathematics
which we are terrible at doing.
But they were terrible at doing things
that we are capable of doing
like understanding that
something is a chair
that was an unsolved
computer vision problem
for a very long time.
But today technologies beginning
to be able to do things like that.
So, recently I got interested in botany
in time of COVID you're
not able to do that much.
So I go for walks and-
- We all get new hobbies, yeah. (chuckles)
- Yeah.
I've never been interested in nature
although I'm in California I'm
not an outdoor kind of person
and I don't much care for exercise.
So the...
But going on walks I was like, well,
what's around me is plants and trees.
And so I began to be interested in like,
well, what are the types of plants
and trees I'm seeing around me?
And there's an app on
Google called Google Lens
that allows you to then
take a picture of a plant
and it'll tell you what it is.
And 10 years ago what I tried this
or even five years ago this
stuff didn't work really well.
And today it works really well.
So you can look at a plant
and begin to figure out what it is
and then go further from
there into like, okay
what are the kinds of plants I'm seeing?
Why are these plants here?
And so for me it's just
a journey of curiosity
but you can see how
something that is a tool
can help me follow that part
of curiosity that I had.
And so I think there are these connections
in the real world that
computers are now able to do.
That would be really useful.
Another example is our use of AR
in augmented reality models
that we provided in search
for things like the skeleton
which allow students visualize a skeleton
or parts of the body in the
context that they are in
without...
In a base where they may
not actually have access to
an actual skeleton in their classroom.
Which is often a useful teaching aid.
So there are many different ways
in which computers are now able
to connect to the real world
that I think could be of
service in a classroom
and could be something that
teachers might find useful.
- That makes sense.
That makes sense.
So, we have a couple
of questions coming in.
We have an interesting question
from Susana Garcia Dominguez on YouTube.
She says that Google is the backbone
of our internet experience.
Are people getting smarter?
She wonders?
- You know, It's a really
interesting question.
And I think from my...
Here's my perspective, when I...
As I use search, there
are times in the past
when I would hit a wall
in what I needed to know
to take the next step, right?
I'm interested in some area
the botany example is one example
but many other areas I'm interested in.
And then I'm interested
in one, some aspect of it.
And the past you'd have to go
to the library, find a book
and actually then read up about it.
And what's the name just didn't do that.
So, but today you can ask that question
and get an answer quickly and then decide
if you wanna take that interest further.
So to my thinking at
least for me personally,
it feels to me that allows me
to develop this kind of
curiosity and exploration
that allows my mind to develop
in a slightly different
way than it could have.
If every time I was
interested in something
it meant finding either the expert in it
or going to a library
to find the right book.
That's often the right situation.
Once I've gotten a little bit
of initial interest, right?
The expert will give you something
that probably a book cannot
and a book will give you something
that a quick answer want.
But still there is
something about being able
to follow those lines
of a curiosity I think
that makes us more curious in the future.
Helps us build that muscle
within us of curiosity.
And I think to me that's
a part of learning I think
that's really the most inspiring,
the most fun and why and
how it can be something
that we pursue all through our lives.
- It's interesting.
We had a guest on yesterday,
who's a cognitive scientist.
And we were also talking about curiosity
and that it can be
powerful but also fragile.
And that we see it in
young kids so often.
And that then it kind of, you know
as we get to be adults we
lose some of that wonder.
And he was talking about the fact that
we are curious about things that we think
we will help us learn something new
about something we already know.
And so that strikes me
as related to this idea
of can we use the internet
and the information to
as you said, hey, I know a
little bit about this plant
and I wanna find out a little bit more
and build that kind of
that piece that I know.
So, it seems like that's a powerful idea
that's keeping people
curious as they get older.
Is that kind of
maintaining curiosity resonates with you?
- Very much so.
And I like that notion of like
there are certain seeds of
curiosity in our everyday lives.
And the question is, will
those seeds find nutrition?
And we can follow where they take that...
Okay, I'm gonna mix
metaphors terribly here.
Where that takes us.
So, I think
that sense of wonder also
about the world around us
that sense of the amazingness
of life of nature.
All of those things can inspire
things within us in a moment
that can then lead us
on to something that lasts for longer.
- That makes sense.
I'm gonna shift gears a little,
we have a question coming in
from (murmurs)
It's actually a suggestion,
but I think it raises a question.
Suggestion was you should
talk to teachers worldwide
not only in the US.
The learning and teaching process nowadays
is less focused on
assignments and quizzes.
We need different tools,
but I'll broaden that out to you.
How are you thinking about working
with teachers globally or internationally?
- It's really important to us.
And we actually do have forums
that reach out worldwide.
We've...
From a personal point of view
I've always been interested in education
in the context of India,
because that's where I grew up.
And I've been
it's something I was a
bit more familiar with.
But I do think
especially during COVID
learning and education
has been experienced also
differently in different places.
And countries are taking different parts.
And so we're very aware of that.
We're working with places
we're working with say
like the Indonesian ministry to figure out
how we can deploy classroom
and make it really useful in that context.
We are thinking about.
We're working in India with
things like Read Along.
There's a lot of different things
that are needed in different contexts.
And we are thinking about those...
That range of needs and what we can build
that will satisfy broad
needs around the world,
but also specialized needs
in particular places that arise.
- Yeah.
That different context is so important.
They mentioned the importance
of tests and quizzes,
and that is something
that is quite different
in different education systems.
And how they think summative tests
and even things like
the size of classrooms
can make a difference.
It seems like...
How do you think about
kind of just assembling...
Speaking of information,
assembling all of that
information together.
So it kind of get your, you know,
build your knowledge base there.
- I think, I mean,
I'm acutely aware of the difference
having come from a different
educational system myself.
And so,
I think that
in many ways we are looking at
education in various countries.
There are some of the countries
like Brazil, Indonesia,
India, to get a sense of what is happening
in different places,
what the needs are in different places.
In many places the way education works
is driven by sort of the government...
By policy, by government policy.
And so we need to understand
what's happening in these
different countries,
on a country by country basis.
And so we are looking
at it in those terms.
- Got it. That makes sense.
So here's again, a bit
of a different question.
But I think I'd be interested to hear
what you have to say from...
Let me see, who is asking
Jennifer Zhao on Facebook.
What do you think are key skills
students should learn to
be ready for the future?
- You know at the end of
the day, (exhales sharply)
the future is going to be...
Changes faster and faster and faster pace.
So one of the key skills
I think is getting
comfortable with learning.
Which is why I come back to
that notion of curiosity,
because that's what makes learning fun.
Because if it's self driven
and it's driven by curiosity,
it makes learning fun.
But that also enables you
to like keep continue to learn over time.
And so I think the key skill ends up being
a little bit meta in my view.
It is that ability to continue to learn.
And to some extent on the particulars
continue to be important.
Language is gonna continue
to be important mathematics
and the sciences and so on
and continue to be important.
But as foundational.
But beyond that I think
there are different skills
that we'll need at over time
that are gonna be hard
to predict right now.
And so being flexible and
adaptable to that future,
I think is gonna be really
important for people
to not just survive, but
thrive in that future.
- So another concern
about the future is equity
and leveling the playing fields.
Is there a role for technology there?
- You know, there are lots of ways
in which we're thinking about this.
Like one example
is how do we...
Is during COVID.
Like a lot of places don't
have access to the internet.
They don't have WiFi access
or high-speed or phone access.
And so we have been working
on making much more of us
of our apps be available offline.
So that people can do work offline
when they're not connected.
Is an example of the kinds of things
that need to be done to enable
that kind of ability to use these tools.
We also been working with
the Indonesian government
on like data availability.
We've been working with making more
Chromebooks available in
California during COVID.
So we're working on like
the overall set of tooling
so that the basic sets of tools
are more broadly available.
And I think that's really
an important aspect
of making education work for everybody.
- Yeah.
Absolutely.
Do you think there's
things that when we
think about in the tools,
there's something that things,
as you're thinking about new
tools that you're creating.
I know there are concerns
as we get more and more
machine learning and AI.
That are we training them the right ways?
Are we just replicating
our existing biases
in these new forms.
There are ways we can think about
making sure we're not doing that.
- You know, that's a
really important question
and we work pretty...
There's a lot of work going on
both in a research sense
as well as in deployment to make sure
to ensure that we have...
We do build more models and so on
that don't reflect biases in society.
It's complex work that involves
both a research component
as well as a deployment component.
And a lot of work is happening on that
in many different areas.
And so I think that's an area of concern
and it's an area that a lot of people
are paying deep attention to.
- Yeah, definitely.
So, as you think about your team
and building out your team.
What are the kinds of
skills and capabilities
that you look for in as you're
building your own teams?
- I was talking about the
teacher who inspired me
who was really passionate about chemistry.
And I looked to a certain extent
for that passion about the topic
because I think anything
we do has difficulties.
I think some things work
out, some things don't.
And having that passion enables people
to like go through those difficulties
work with them, deal with
when things don't work out.
Because you have that
larger goal in mind of like
what you're trying to...
Trying to do.
And so I think that's an important aspect
of what I look for
in people who are working
in this organization.
And I think it holds
for many different parts
of the two kinds of
tools we're working on.
So this includes things
like Google Scholar
which is used by researchers
and the people working on-
- I use it a lot. (laughs)
- Yeah.
The people are extremely passionate
about making researchers
lives more productive
having them get more access to papers
and all the sets of
things that make research
and the information needed for research,
more available and useful.
Google arts and culture
is trying to get...
Is getting a whole by working
with cultural institutes
to make those sorts of experiences
more available to people around the world.
And all of these things
are not necessarily always easy to do.
They take a knowledge...
They take a certain degree of humility
because we don't know what is often needed
in many of these areas.
So, in the area
of education,
I want to understand what teachers need.
In the area of scholar
they are trying to understand
what researchers need.
So, in each of these areas,
the thing I'm looking for also is that
a certain degree of humility
in trying to understand
what people's needs are
so that we can actually serve those needs.
- That makes sense.
So kind of looking for folks
that have that user-centric
- Yes.
- Or ideas that make sense.
And Google has this focus on the user
and other things will follow.
But and it's something that
I really do believe in,
like whether it's a teacher or the student
we have to focus on what they need.
- Got it.
We have one more question about you
coming in from YouTube,
Susana Garcia Dominguez asks.
What sacrifices have you
made in your own journey
to get where you are today?
- It's an interesting question.
I think
I've been very fortunate in my life
in some of the choices I made.
But I did choose to go into
computer science at a time
when it wasn't...
It was something that was a passion for me
but it was not really
that widely,
it was not that important an area.
I think when I didn't think of it
I don't tend to think of sort of...
I didn't think of other
people's sacrifices
as being far greater than my own,
the sacrifices sort of
that my parents made
the teachers around me made.
I feel I've been really
fortunate and a beneficiary
of a lot of
what other people around me have done.
And I feel the need to serve
others as a result of that.
Because I think
there's a lot that other people from my...
Including my parents and so on have done,
I think that I have benefited from
and I think that's a thought
that stays with me quite often.
- Yeah, yeah.
Tell me a little bit more
about now computer science
of course, is where everyone says,
oh if you wanna be successful
and be attach to the future,
go into computer science.
But it's interesting that
when you were starting out
that was not the case.
So was it something that you
were just really interested in
or what made you pursue that
even though it wasn't maybe
being as popular then?
- Yeah.
And when I going...
When I started out, a lot of people were,
there's people who were persuading me
to try and go into one of
the fields like medicine
or law or things of that.
- Sure.
- But my own interest
was in building things.
I think is some inherent,
inherently there's an engineer in me.
And so there's that
aspect of building things
was something that always appealed to me.
And so computer science was something
that inherently just
repealed the first time
I saw a computer.
And so it was something
that drew me very early on.
And it's something that the
pleasure of building things,
I think is something of
creating or building something
is something that
doesn't go away from you.
Because I think it can
play a role in your life
all the way through in small
things or in larger ways.
- Got it.
What advice would you have
for learners that are,
just now kind of coming up
and thinking about their future education
and their future careers?
- I think these,
what has served me well, actually
is a breadth of interests.
Because when I started
working, even at Google,
I worked on infrastructure
projects within Google
on page rank and things like
that, I worked on ranking.
But then I began to be involved
with user interfaces
and things of that sort.
But what I felt that served me well
was finding out what's
interesting in that area.
And then being able to pursue it.
So, I would say find the interesting thing
in almost anything that you are learning
and pursue that it gets
to what makes learning,
I think, interesting and
fun and not just a task.
So that's the piece.
And then when it is interesting,
when it is more than just a task to do,
I think you get much more out of it
and not just in the short-term,
but in the long-term.
- Great.
That seems like good
advice for us to end on.
So thank you so much for joining us today.
We appreciate having you.
- Thank you so much
Kristen, for having me here.
- Great.
And to all of our guests,
thanks for joining us today.
All of those out there listening
and we will see you next time.
(bright music)